when you're living in survival you're
living in stress emotions of anger and
aggression and hatred and judgment and
fear and anxiety and guilt and shame
when you're living by those hormones
you're always going to try to force an
outcome control an outcome the quantum
model of reality actually then creates
an energetic field so that instead of
you going out there and getting it and
it takes time you are collapsing time
and space and it is being drawn to you
the difference between third dimensional
creation and fifth dimensional creation
third dimensional creation takes time
but in fifth dimensional creation you're
not going anywhere to get it you are
actually drawing it you are the vortex
that's collapsing time and space and
it's your energy that's bringing it to
you now that then begins to become the
excitement because now you're no longer
trying to control or predict the outcome
you're trusting the outcome you're
trusting in the unknown you had never
analyzed where it's going to happen or
when it's going to happen because you
understand that the moment you do that
you just return back to the old self the
process then of creating from that state
of mind and body then means that we have
have to lay down the very thing we used
our whole life to get what we want for
something greater to occur and that's
why it takes us sometimes in our events
four or five days to have students
Retreat from their lives long enough and
if you are going to heal your body by
thought alone create something in your
life by thought alone then you have to
become thought alone hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I struggle
to believe in myself I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was watching the successful
stories of entrepreneurs they gave me
the inspiration to keep going as well as
the strategies of what to do and quite
honestly I still need their stories and
motivation today as well so Taylor Swift
your best believe life and learn how to
let go and let the universe draw to us
enjoy
rule number two is get in touch with
your Consciousness with Eckhart Tolle
Jesus wasn't talking about lots of
things he's talking about the core of
Life the fullness that you that is
inseparable from what what when we
started
or today we started with getting in
touch with the
the Consciousness within you to realize
the con that you are conscious that the
essence of who you are is the awareness
not your history the essence of who you
are is the awareness and the awareness
of that awareness
is
the realization
of
that which is prior to all forms
that can become forms but that the
[Music]
that which that which is prior to all
the manifestations
is the the the
unmanifested life the one the
Consciousness the one life that
underlies the entire universe and
because you are only a microscopic
version of the entire universe you can
discover
virtually all the secrets of the
universe by going Within
because you are inseparable from the
universe
you this you discover the most
incredible deepest realizations not not
factual things you may not know how many
how many planets have
life intelligent life in our galaxy
nobody knows not those things but the
deeper
laws and movements that aren't a lie
the manifestation of the universe you
can find that within yourself by going
Within
so
the abundance is
the aliveness that is within you and
it's the awareness of that aliveness but
the awareness of that aliveness and the
aliveness are a single thing isn't The
Duality arises when we talk about it
then they can say oh I'm aware of
consciousness
but you're not you can't be aware of
Consciousness because the awareness is
the Consciousness the Consciousness is
the awareness so Consciousness is
becoming self-aware and what is that
constant it's not yours it's the
consciousness of the universe
manifesting through this little form
so the you are part of the Awakening
process of the universe so all
manifestation that you do in your life
must be aligned with the Awakening
universe and the universe is moving
towards
greater consciousness
but where does it come from it comes
from an unmanifested
source of all life that is traditionally
has been called God
the source of all life emanates into
this universe but it has it has no
location in space or time it is beyond
that
but to realize that the essence of who
you are is inseparable from that
that is when the the Ripple on the
surface of the Ocean Suddenly realizes
that it is the ocean yes it's also a
rebel not for long for a little while
it's also the Ripple but in essence the
rebel is the ocean and when the rebel
becomes aware if it's of its true nature
then that means the ocean
just become aware of its true nature the
totality of life has become a has woken
up
that is our so everything that we do in
our many what we want to manifest let's
make sure that it is part of the
evolving Consciousness so even the
simplest things let's say you want to
manifest a that's your hairdresser and
now you want to manifest now that you
can
salons are open again okay I'm going to
to have a hairdressing Salon okay I'm
going to focus on that and I can feel
that I already have it because I can
feel the fullness of life already and it
does bring in the image of this
hairdressing salon and and it bring it
into this sense of fullness which means
you're already feeling that it's there
and whether it comes secondary now
let's see you you become a more very
powerful Manifesto if you do not depend
on some future outcome that you already
experience in the fullness of life but
you also know that this hairdressing
Salon is
a place where people will when they go
when they go there they not only get a
good haircut
or hairdo
they also get your presence they also
get your attention they also get the
energy that you emanate there and they
will feel better while the you're
cutting their hair I'm just giving one
example I could give thousands of
examples
they feel in that moment they feel you
listen to them you acknowledge that
they're not just a client you
acknowledge their beingness
I always say the human being has a
two-dimension the human is the condition
with the history the being is the
unconditioned so that's the
Consciousness that you are that is a
Transcendent Dimension rule number three
is trust the universe with Louise Hay
whenever I speak somewhere someone will
come up to me at the end of the lecture
or will write me a letter and tell me
that he or she has had a healing take
place while they were in the room
sometimes it's very minor and sometimes
it's quite dramatic a woman came up to
me once and told me that she had had a
lump in her breast and it literally
disappeared during the lecture
she heard something and she decided to
let something go
this is a good example of how powerful
we are
when we are not ready to let something
go when we really want to hold on to
something because it's serving Us in
some way it doesn't matter what we do it
probably won't work however when we are
ready to let it go as this woman was
it's amazing how the smallest
circumstance can help us release it
if you still have a habit that you
haven't released ask yourself how it
serves you what do you get out of it
if you can't get an answer ask in a
different way
if I no longer had this habit what would
happen
very often the answer is my life would
be better
so it comes back to the fact that we
believe we don't deserve a better life
in some way
ordering from the cosmic kitchen
when you first say an affirmation it may
not seem true but remember affirmations
are like planting seeds in the ground
when you put a seed in the ground you
don't get a full-grown plant the next
day
we need to be patient during the growing
season as you continue to say the
affirmation either you will be ready to
release whatever you don't want and the
affirmation will become true or it will
open a new Avenue to you or you may get
a brilliant brainstorm or a friend may
call you and say have you tried this you
will be led to the next step that will
help you
keep your affirmations in the present
tense you can sing them and make a
jingle out of them so that they repeat
over and over in your hand remember that
you cannot affect a specific person's
actions with your affirmations to affirm
that John is now in love with me is a
form of manipulation and it is trying to
have control over another person's life
it will usually have a boomerang effect
on you you will become very unhappy when
you don't get what you want you can say
I am now loved by a wonderful man who is
and lists the qualities that you want in
the relationship that way you allow the
power within you to bring to you the
perfect person to fill that bill who may
possibly be John
you don't know what another person's
spiritual lesson is and you don't have a
right to interfere in their life process
you certainly wouldn't want someone else
doing it to you if someone is ill bless
them and send them love and peace but
don't demand that they get well
I like to think of doing affirmations as
placing our order in the cosmic kitchen
if you go to a restaurant and the waiter
or waitress comes and takes your order
you don't follow them into the kitchen
to see if the chef got the order or how
he's going to prepare the food you sit
and drink water or coffee or tea or you
talk to your friend and maybe Eat Your
Role you assume that your food is being
prepared and will be out when it's ready
it's the same when we begin to do
affirmations
when we put our order into the cosmic
kitchen the great chef our higher power
is working on it so you go on with your
life and know that it is being taken
care of it's on order it's happening
now if the food comes out and it isn't
exactly what you ordered and if you have
self-esteem you will send it back if not
you will eat it you also have a right to
do that with the cosmic kitchen if you
don't get exactly what you want you can
say no that's not quite it this is what
I want perhaps you weren't clear in your
ordering
the idea here too is to let go
at the end of my treatments and
meditations I use the words and so it is
it's a way of saying higher power it's
in your hands now I release it to you
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is Don't Force
things with Gabby Bernstein better
manifesting is like when you're you know
reading all the books and you've got the
vision board and you're like saying
mantras and you're making wish lists and
you're looking for signs and you're just
forcing forcing forcing
you know being in a relationship with
the universe with an energy beyond your
own is like any relationship if if
you're dating somebody and you're just
like constantly calling and constantly
like trying to make another plan they're
gonna be like out like you know thank
you and so I think that that's very
similar with our relationship to the
universe and that we are often pushing
and controlling and so we're missing
that response we're blocking the actual
communication we're just having a
one-way conversation
and so to be in communion with that
connection you have to communicate you
have to listen you have to not just ask
but you have to listen
you have to slow down and then that
Stillness is when you can start to get
messages I love that word communion that
you just used
there's something that feels peaceful
about that yeah totally
Oprah's podcast at the beginning she has
uh this line she says want it wish for
it let it go yeah which is kind of the
key right that's it I think letting it
go is part of the manic manifestation
issue totally feels totally like if you
want something
how do you let it go well it's funny
that you said that so I did a Super Soul
sessions talk for her and it's on her
podcast for Oprah and it's all about
surrender yeah and it's also based on a
chapter in the universe has your back
all and the spiritual steps to surrender
so that would be a good resource for
somebody to go to YouTube and just watch
that surrender the spiritual steps to
surrender that's a I mean it lays it out
for you completely but I think that the
biggest thing is to forget what you
think you need what you think you need
is actually so much smaller than what's
actually possible for you so let that go
and open your you can want what you want
right ask for is that what she said want
what you want want it wish for it want
it wish for it let it go I think they
just follow over there rule number five
is be patient with Mel Robbins I need
you to understand something
for manifesting to work properly based
on Research there is no timeline
involved
did you hear me
for manifesting to work properly based
on the research there is no timeline
involved
you must give up the when
and you must focus on
seeing and feeling yourself taking the
steps that make the thing that you want
happen because manifesting is not
magically making something appear
manifesting is preparing your mind body
and spirit to do the work to make
something happen it's aligning your
thoughts your actions and how you feel
in your body with the thing that you
want and the reason why manifesting is
important is because when you prepare
yourself to do the work and to start to
see and feel it you will believe that
it's a foregone conclusion you will
believe that at some point it will
happen and you will believe that you can
make it happen and that belief is why
you feel inspired and encouraged to take
action you see when you suspend the
timeline and you get rid of deadlines
there is no room for being in patient
because you in your heart and your soul
and in your mind know that at some point
if you just keep on manifesting and you
keep on seeing yourself and feeling
yourself doing the steps that you need
in order to make this a reality
eventually it'll happen
so if you feel impatient you're doing it
wrong
because you're not supposed to attach a
timeline to it you're supposed to wake
up every morning and write down five
things that you want and let yourself
see and feel yourself doing the work and
that will inspire you to take the
actions that lead you there and if you
do that every day trust me you want to
be thinking about the timeline because
you know in your heart and soul
eventually this is going to turn out and
rule number six the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is stop
resisting with Rhonda burn we have all
kinds of different things that give us a
perception and again since it's so hard
to see ourselves it's like you have to
have these moments right where you go oh
so what is the Letting Go process then
so the technique to help release things
and I keep working on it all of the time
because
um in fact I just said to my daughter I
have to find a simpler way of saying
this I I just want it to be simpler and
I've covered it in my book The Greatest
Secret but I still like I'm always
looking for simpler simple as simple
ways so
one of the things just to understand so
people can get the feeling is one of the
things that we do is we resist all the
way along in our life we resist when
something happens that we don't want to
happen and I don't want that we resist
and so we we're kind of
um enjoying this like the things we like
but the things we don't like we like
pushing them away including including
people or a comment that somebody makes
we don't like that comment and it
affects us and so
um and so that's all resistance and
resistance is what causes all the
negative feelings and contractions
inside of us and so what releasing does
is it stops us from resisting and so it
if a negative subject arises a negative
memory a negative feeling it is because
we have just resisted and so to
counteract that testing and stop that
resisting we do the opposite to
resisting and so what we do is like I
could say just like relax but I say
welcome it welcome the feeling welcome
the the memory welcome the thought and
it's really just that we we don't try
and fix it we don't try and change it we
don't try and make it go away we don't
try and do anything to it we just allow
it
to be there and in the allowing of it to
be there we stop resisting and it just
the energy just evaporates and very
often you can feel the energy unwinding
in your chest it's just an automatic
cleansing system in our body the moment
we stop resisting
everything unwinds and so you could just
do this if if nothing appeared you could
just be really relaxed and just allowing
of everything to be just the way it is
right now and so to be very present as
well of course helps to do that and then
if all the energy that is trapped just
begins to unwind and be released and why
we don't need to go through picking one
trauma one memory after another is
because
many of them attach like a train with
carriages and so we can get one and it
just pulls the whole train of carriages
oh God at the same time and takes a
whole takes a whole lot of memories with
it and so we don't need to go through
anything one by one or we just need to
see the ones that appear the ones that
are triggered the you know the feelings
that that are triggered by an outside
event I know that you talked about
mirroring and and that's what's so
beautiful is that I mean I can use the
universe as an example we'll use people
circumstances and events it will use all
of those things to show us what needs to
be released you know and and so it's
just everything that happens to us is
the most beautiful gift steeped in love
and designed for us to be happier and to
be free and so that's how I release now
you get real you get that good at it
that I don't even know how I do it now I
just kind of you feel a relief you just
uh
you just kind of welcome and and just
sort of
sort of sink and you immediately feel a
sense of relief through your body and
you just feel this thing dissipate and
disappear and it's amazing you can have
a really strong emotion and it will just
evaporate that's the best feeling in the
whole world
the beautiful thing about monk life is
half the day is self and half the day is
service that's how you're taught to live
okay so the morning hours are for you to
fill yourself it's almost like putting
on mental emotional and physical armor
like that's what a morning routine is
our days are tiring our days are busy
our days are draining well guess what if
you didn't put your armor on in the
morning and you're going out to battle
how many knives are going to cut you how
many swords are going to pierce you how
many wounds are you going to come home
with how many of you come back home
feeling wounded I come back home feeling
wounded sometimes but guess what if you
put your armor on in the morning a
warrior would never go out onto a
Battlefield
and life can be a battlefield work can
be full of conflict sometimes your
relationships can be damaging sometimes
your friendships can be toxic sometimes
so we are warriors in one sense and so
without wearing that so for me a morning
routine is putting on emotional armor
which is meant to protect you for the
rest of the day and that way even if you
do get pierced or you do get popped or
you do get cut you're protected and I
know that when I my morning routine is
at its best I feel protected I know
exactly whereas when my morning routine
is weakened I feel weak and so for me
the morning routine as I get strategic
about it there's two principles you have
to know
location has energy and time has memory
if you do something in the same place
every day that place now holds that
energy
and this is huge like it's it's just so
big and I'm grateful for that reaction
because people don't realize how how
powerful this is like when I meditated
in temples that were 5 000 years old in
South India it was easier to meditate
because people have been meditating
there for thousands of years and so when
you find a space in your home and even
if you've got like I lived in a 500
square foot apartment in New York four
years ago and I just had a tiny Corner
which I dedicated to my sacred practices
so if you you don't have to have a big
home to do this you don't have to be
wealthy to do this you can find just a
corner in your home that you dedicate as
your meditation space or your reflection
space so first thing location has energy
second thing time has memory and this is
something that people underestimate when
you do something at the same time every
day
you remember it
and time remembers it that's why we
struggle to work out at different times
every day it's why we struggle like why
do we feel hungry at the same time every
day generally we feel hungry at the same
time most people if you've got regulated
diet you're full hungry you'll feel
tired at the same time every day you
will look towards that coke can or that
sugar or that chocolate bar at the same
time every day
and so when you're meditating at the
same time if you're exercising at the
same time so what I recommend to people
wow is your morning routine needs four
aspects and it's simple and I call it
time it's about making time in the day
okay so time stands for t-i-m-e T stands
for thankfulness there needs to be even
if it's five minutes five minutes of
thankfulness of gratitude every single
morning and that has to be gratitude
that's specific it can't be gratitude
that's generic so generic gratitude is
something that anyone could be grateful
for oh I'm grateful for the sky I'm
grateful for air I'm grateful for water
that's cool but it's generic gratitude
specific gratitude is I'm grateful for
the fact that I have someone calling me
this morning I'm grateful for the fact
that I can still call my parents I'm
grateful for the fact that I have this
person in my business who is having such
an impact I'm grateful you know it's
specificity yeah so thankfulness second
one is Insight I think this is one thing
that a lot of people are missing which I
recommend people listening to you it's
like podcast books and and make it
easier for yourself if you get this book
leave it open on your bedside table
leave it open on your kitchen table
leave it open on your dining table I
guarantee you you will read more and
what you read will speak to you and I
think people underestimate that that
literally like when you have it open and
you'll just flick to a chapter randomly
and you'll pick up one line it will
impact you and it'll speak to you so
Insight you need Insight every day m is
meditation and I believe meditation is
different for different people as monks
we did walking meditations we did Beach
meditations we did visualizations we did
breath work find your meditation
practice I give a ton in the book and
fourth obviously exercise which you can
speak to even more than I can I exercise
to keep fit you look amazing too though
but it's an exercise everyone needs to
find five minutes a day 15 minutes a day
of exercise
consistent action is the cure-all
whatever problem you have whatever issue
you're facing whatever big life you want
to create for yourself the way to get
there is not some giant
short burst of effort it's the daily
consistent grinding action that will
help you accomplish your goals people
look at my channel and
a lot of new people have joined over the
past number of years hey welcome board
great to have you welcome to believe
Nation it's a positive happy place it's
great to have you here it's an honor to
be a part of your daily routine
if you go and look at my my channel my
main channel in the history it took so
many years guys so many years of just
making content and not seeing any
results
I took I forget what the number is it
took five years to get to 9 000
something subscribers and another five
years to get to almost 2 million
subscribers now we're sitting over three
million subscribers Etc
I haven't missed
an upload every single day
for I don't know
eight years
something crazy like that
every day
I've made videos through
travel I've made videos through elect
electricity electricity outages I made
videos through breaking my neck I made
videos through my tour I made videos
through vacation I made videos I made
videos I made videos I made videos I
made videos I made videos and you can
plan you can prepare you can get ahead
you can you can batch them
but I don't think your goals count until
they're hard
it's when it gets hard when when you get
tested that's when you have to show
yourself What You're Made Of
even little things like
I remember filming at my dance studio in
Toronto
and I have my camera guy and my
assistant and we're filming and the
electricity goes out
and then there's a fire alarm
they go I guess we can't film like the
first thing that that my camera guy says
is okay well I guess we can't film but I
can't film with this like electricity
outage and then fire alarm
you can't film with that it's like I'm
I'm filming today
so I took my phone it was freezing
outside I took my phone went outside and
just started filming
because videos have to go up
they have to go up
I've I've made videos with my broken
neck
I broke my neck in two spots had a
concussion
and I
next week I'm making videos
they weren't as long they weren't as
good
I'm wearing a neck brace if you look at
the old videos I'm wearing this giant
neck brace I got this giant scab here on
my forehead because I smashed my head
against the wall
when I fainted and that's how it led to
the concussion broken neck I'm still
making videos
not making videos is not an option
and so if you look at someone like me
who
is introverted is shy who doesn't like
the camera who always thought that
people who are famous had a big ego who
I still don't like being on stage I
still get nervous every single time
but I still have a message
and I still want to serve how does
somebody like that
have this kind of Channel well because
of every single day making videos you've
done over 10 000 videos I've done over
10 000 videos that's crazy
not all of them are public
but even just on the main Channel let
alone this channel on the top 10 channel
the other channel 10 000 Plus videos
over 12 years
why
how
it's just a consistent action
I think most people lose because
we overestimate what we can do
in a really
short period of time and underestimate
what we can do in a long period of time
you think by putting in three weeks of
hard work you're gonna crush it
but really if you just stayed on it like
guys you've had ideas you have enough
you've you have had an idea that you've
loved that you gave up on too soon that
if you just kept doing it this is an
idea that you had maybe three years ago
that if you just found the way to keep
doing it even part-time even on the side
even on the weekends if you just kept at
it you'd be in a different place right
now
something would have happened something
would have paid off
but we're too frustrated to get
something to happen right now and I get
it I'm there too I'm I'm impatient I
want immediate results I want things to
happen I'm putting my best I want this
video right now to be the best one I've
ever done and I put my effort to try to
make that happen and I fully recognize
at the same time that
it's a long game
that you have to keep going
and that it's your purpose you can't
give up on it
most people just quit too soon
you just quit too soon
and that's you quitting on your dream
and it was your dream and you want it to
happen it's a daily consistent action to
make it happen
so how do you do it let me give you some
tactics so that you can not just get
motivated from a message but actually
apply it to your life number one you
have to create a calendar
these videos happen because they're in
my calendar
I'm filming this on a Tuesday Tuesday is
my YouTube day I always film on Tuesday
I block it off in my calendar
I just came back from vacation and on
the Tuesday of my week I was still
making videos people say well still work
on vacation first off it's not work like
I like this this is fun for me this
isn't this isn't oh I have to go make
videos if that was my mindset I would
I'd be out I wouldn't do it anymore
but also if you're on vacation you're
making videos or you're doing a little
bit of work
to spend three hours
of a 24-hour day
doing something
is totally achievable somebody one of
the people that I invested into
yesterday's like how do I take a
vacation on my business
like how do I my wife wants to know how
do I go on vacation and run this
business like you can still you can
either plan ahead and get ahead with all
your clients or you can still do some
work
do you not have personal time are you
going to be around your wife 24 hours a
day does your wife not want to go to the
spa or spend some time on the beach it's
not about the three hours that you spend
working it's about
the other hours at 21 hours you get to
sleep but whatever all the other hours
that you have the day it's about
intentional time most of most people's
life is not intentional most of your
vacation time is not intentional either
if you were to spend 21 hours a day with
your wife
intentionally creating an amazing
relationship
then the three hours a day you're going
to spend working
as easy as nothing
of course you could take time off
but you have to put in your calendar
you have to create a calendar that makes
sense for you
schedule in when you're actually going
to make your dreams happen because
otherwise it's a dream I could say I
want to make YouTube videos but if it
was never my calendar guess what it
would never happen and this applies for
life too every uh every afternoon
at 2 30 I spend time with Nina with my
wife
we spend time in the morning I take an
intentional break at 2 30 we go to the
park we take we take the dogs with us
we we stay inside and just be together
if it's raining like we'll spend time
every day every weekday at 2 30 because
I want I wanted to spend more time with
Nina during the week weekends we're
basically all in on on the relationship
but the weekdays can be crazy you know
so we spend time in the morning we spend
time in the evening and I wanted to
spend
2 30. it's 25 minutes together but
intentional 25 minutes that intentional
25 minutes is worth more than three
hours of just sitting in front of a TV
that's not time together
you have a lot more time than you think
just not being intentional that's the
problem if you feel like you got to the
end of the week and you were so busy but
you got nothing done
and everything's falling apart you're
just not intentional with your time
so you schedule it in whatever you
wanted a life whatever your dream life
looks like whatever your goals Ambitions
motivations are put in your calendar
two
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
stop letting yourself off the hook
for not following through on your
calendar
I'm a little tired today because we just
came back from our trip I'm a little jet
lagged from coming out from the West
I'm still making videos I'm still videos
have to be made they're going up like
when do you let yourself break
if it's in the calendar it has to happen
videos have to happen today I don't care
if I'm lying in bed I don't care I don't
care if I'm in the hospital I've made
videos from the hospital I don't care
where videos have to come up I don't
care if they're the best videos they're
the best
with what I can make right now
if I'm tired they might be lower than my
standard but it's the best of what I can
make right now if I'm in the hospital
it's definitely lower than what I can
make out of the hospital but I'm gonna
make the best of what I can make right
now
be the person who follows through on the
things that you say you're gonna do
because the next time you put something
in your calendar the next time we see
you're gonna get that goal or
do this project you're going to the next
day wake up I'm not I can't do that I'm
not doing that
you're starting to build the identity
either way of the person who follows
through or the person who doesn't follow
through
and every time you say yes to yourself
every time you do it when it's difficult
you start to build up that identity a
little bit more I follow through I
follow through I follow through so then
the next time you put something in your
calendar the next time come up with a
goal you start to believe that it's
actually possible for you to do it
because you're building that identity of
you being the person who actually
follows through
and every time you let yourself off the
hook every time you give yourself a
break every time you say it's okay I'm
not going to do it today every time you
say that
you eat away at that other identity and
start to build a new one
the new identity of the person who
doesn't follow through
you start to believe yourself a little
bit less
the next goal you write down is a little
less credible you don't think you can do
it you're going to realize the next day
that you're not going to follow through
and says it's very
slippery slope to fall down
so step one is you build a calendar step
two is you become the person who sticks
to your calendar
who follows through on the things that
you say you're going to do that's why
it's important to create a realistic
calendar don't tell me don't tell
yourself you're going to make 100 videos
a day every day
you're going to make a thousand phone
calls a day every day
you're not you're going to write 100
love letters to your wife every day
you're not you're not it's not going to
happen make it a realistic plan for
something you can actually stick to
because again if you just stick to it
guys you will hit your goals
if you stop quitting on yourself if you
stop letting yourself off the hook that
idea you had three years ago should have
already come to Creation because you
just stuck with it just stick with it
step number three so create a calendar
one stick to your calendar number two
three
the environment around you really
matters
videos like this really matters why
create the inspressor to be with you
every morning to give you the Boost to
bring new people like John astraff and
Oprah and Elon Musk and these people who
lift you up who inspire you hopefully
that's the intention every time
join a group like movement makers be a
part of a community be around other
entrepreneurs who are doing things we're
chasing their dreams we're trying to
make their thing happen when you're when
you create that environment and you
start to shift it
it inspires you to want to play bigger
it inspires you to want to stay
consistent when you are feeling at your
lowest low when you're about to quit on
the thing that you said that you want to
do that's in your calendar you see it
you see it today I'm supposed to do that
like I don't want to do that what brings
you out of it
it's the habits it's the environment
it's the routine
watch another video
join our group like movement makers
get a mentor coach
have an accountability buddy
you have to be around the people who
constantly fill your cup who give you
light who lift you up who make you
believe and help you feel like it's
possible when you do those three things
your life will change
create a calendar
that mapped your actions to your
ambitions
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
and then be around the people videos
resources environment
that encourages you that lifts you up
and makes you feel like it's possible
what is fear
here's something that you should feel
I want you to imagine as you're driving
down the street in your car
and a light pops up on the dashboard a
light pops up
um
have you ever taken a hammer and hit the
light because you don't like the light
of course not that would be silly right
what if the light on the dashboard was
just a signal maybe you're low on tire
air pressure maybe uh you're missing air
or water in your windshield wiper maybe
the back trunk door is open isn't the
signal in your car
just for you to be aware that maybe
something is wrong or something needs
attention
is it possible that if we stop thinking
of fear as the enemy fear is one of your
biggest friends why well when you
understand how did this organism
okay develop and how does it keep us
alive
it pays attention to things okay in your
external World triggers from your
external word that could cause your
death or distraction it causes you to do
what when there is a Potential
Threat predator or threat at the door it
lights up the fear signals since
cortisol epinephrine or norepinephrine
into your bloodstream so you either know
how to fight it you run away or you
freeze hoping that the Predator will go
away so when your brain every brain
gets this signal that there is a threat
at the door
it sends a signal
in the form of a neurochemical that you
feel
now if somebody
feels this threat in their body but they
don't know how to manage the emotion we
call fear let's say there's a fear that
you have a failure and what it might
mean to your family what what about a
fear of losing money and not having
enough to pay the rent the mortgage or
for retirement what if there's a fear of
trying something and then it not working
out and you're embarrassed or ashamed or
ridiculed or rejected or judged oh my
God if you judge me then you're gonna
reinforce my low self-esteem of myself
and then oh then who am I
you understand what's happening in the
circuits I'm just describing
so when our brain has this Fierce
circuit activated do you think the fear
circuit causes you to go oh hey let's
take action anyway or do you think it
goes high alert high alert high alert be
aware what's going on what if you fail
what if you succeed would succeed and
fail whenever that circuit is triggered
motivational circuit shuts down whenever
that circuit is activated your thinking
circuit shuts down all the blood flow
goes into a part of your brain to help
you do what possibly run away protect
yourself it's a protection mechanism but
here is what I want you to remember this
automatic trigger and circuit has been
evolving for millions of years but your
specific experiences since you were born
in the modeling experiential and the
um and the imprinting years caused you
to have
beliefs about things some Empower you
some disempower let me give you an
example
okay let me give you an example when I
say the word
or let me give you a different uh the
same example with just a little
different story
if I say to you that I'd like to take a
big snake about five feet long and let
it Slither across your arm and around
your neck and it's a python how many of
you go oh wow that would be great
versus how many of you are going oh my
God let me run away get get it off of me
just just think of a snake slithering on
you and curling itself around your neck
how many of you are like run versus oh
my God that would be great to take a
picture of me with it so I put on social
media
so is it really the snake that is the
threat or is it your Concept in your
brain the meaning that you have
associated with a snake that is
activating for some of you the reward
center and for others the fear Center
same stake stained stimuli there isn't
even a snake here I just add you think
about it
right and it triggered that fear circuit
for some reward circuit for others so
it's never about the thing so when we
have fear of being embarrassed ashamed
ridiculed judged uh fear of
disappointing ourselves fear of failing
fear of succeeding there's 50 different
types of fears we automatically trigger
the circuit that does what stops our
action taking you will never find
working a pleasure if you hate your job
or you can't stand your boss
what a terrible affirmation that is it
will be impossible for you to ever
attract a great job with that belief
system if you want to enjoy your time at
work then you must change your thinking
I'm a great believer in blessing with
love every person place and thing at the
workplace begin with your current job
affirm that this job is merely a
stepping stone to far greater positions
you are in your current job because of
the things you believed in the past you
drew it to you by your thinking perhaps
you learned your attitude towards work
from your parents no matter you can
change your thinking now
so bless with love your boss your
co-workers the location the building the
stairs or elevators the rooms the
furniture and each and every customer
this creates a loving mental atmosphere
within you and the whole office will
respond to it
I have never understood the reasoning
behind putting down or berating others
at work if you are an owner a manager or
supervisor how can you possibly expect
to get the best work from others if they
are frightened or resentful we all want
to be appreciated acknowledged and
encouraged
if you support your employees and give
them respect then they will give you the
best work they can
now please don't believe that it is hard
to get a job that may be true for many
but it does not have to be true for you
you only need one job and your
Consciousness will open the pathway for
you don't have faith in fear when you
hear of negative Trends in business or
in the economy immediately affirm that
may be true for some but it is not true
for me I always Prosper no matter where
I am or what is going on
people often ask me for the affirmations
to make the relationships at work be
smoother in fact for many people this is
a really big issue in their lives I am
deeply aware that whatever I give out
comes back to me multiplied and this is
true everywhere including at work
in the workplace it is important to know
that every employee and employer has
been attracted by the action of love for
it's his and her divine right place here
and now at this point in time and space
Divine Harmony permeates us all and we
can all flow together in the workplace
in a most productive and joyous way
there aren't any problems that don't
have Solutions there aren't any
questions without answers
choose to go beyond the problem to seek
the Divine Right action solution to any
Discord that may seem to appear
be willing to learn from any Discord or
confusion as it comes up it's important
to release all blame and turn within to
seek the truth
and be willing to release whatever
pattern may be in your Consciousness
that has contributed to the situation
know that you are successful in all that
you do you're inspired and productive
you serve others willingly and gladly
Divine Harmony Reigns Supreme within and
around you and within and around each
and every person in your workplace
when you know and declare that it's
possible to successfully operate in the
workplace according to Divine principles
then Divine love brings to you those who
can be helped by that which you so
lovingly do
now if you like your job but feel you're
not getting paid enough then bless your
current salary with love
expressing gratitude for what you do
have enables it to grow
and absolutely no more bitching about
the job or co-workers your Consciousness
puts you where you are now your changing
Consciousness can lift you to a better
position you can do it
during your work day there are a number
of things you can do to release tension
here are a few ideas
one before you go to work every day do
this simple exercise just sit
comfortably and concentrate on your
breath
whenever you notice thoughts coming in
gently bring your awareness back to your
breath
give yourself at least 10 or 15 minutes
to dwell in the silence each day there
is nothing difficult or tricky to this
and it's worth taking the time
two write or type this affirmation and
put it where you can see it at work my
job is a peaceful Haven I bless my job
with love I put love in every corner and
my job lovingly responds with warmth and
comfort I am at peace
when you start to think about your boss
say this affirmation to yourself
I only give out that which I wish to
receive my love and acceptance of others
is mirrored to me in every way
refuse to be limited in any way by human
mind thinking
your life can be filled with love and
joy because your work is a Divine idea
remember to say to yourself every day
before going to work no matter where I
am there is only infinite good Infinite
Wisdom infinite Harmony and love the
science that says there are two minds
that are operating at the same time one
is called the conscious mind or one is
called the subconscious mind I say
What's the difference
the conscious mind is where you are as a
spirit an entity a unique identity you
are in that conscious mind and
perceiving the world I said what about
the subconscious mind it's not a
creative mind the subconscious mind is
habits things that you've learned and
you've experienced in your life and they
become habits so uh the subconscious
mind is not thinking creating a
subconscious mind push the button play
the behavior
so here's the point
when we are in our conscious mind we are
connecting our spirituality to the
biology and the physical planet that
we're in and that is the creative mind
that's the one you wake up in the
morning and say oh I wish I had this and
I desire that and these are the things I
want and then you go out and start the
day and then guess what
95 of the day you are not operating from
the conscious mind science is recognize
95 of the day because we are thinking 95
of the day our behavior is now
controlled by the subconscious mind
I go okay so what's the difference in
the final conclusion of this is the
conscious mind with your creativity has
your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people your mother your father
your siblings and your community so what
is the difference you wake up with a
wish and a desire of what you want
and then the rest of the day you play
the programs that you got from other
people that don't answer your wishes and
don't support your desires and all you
see is the consequence of it and go oh
my God why is it not working the answer
is because you don't see because
remember the name is subconscious below
conscious so when that behavior is
playing psychologists will tell us 70
percent or more of the programs in the
subconscious are disempowering
self-sabotaging and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this we have
great wishes and desires and yet our
life is not controlled by that our life
is controlled by the programming and
that programming is the disempowering
program so all you see is the
consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage all the
desires and wishes you have and then to
conclude that
what if you just didn't default to the
subconscious what if you just stayed in
the conscious mind that's called being
Mindful and why is it relevant because
when you stay conscious keep your mind
present you are the creator of your life
and when people are in mindfulness they
manifest their wishes their desires and
their happiness so for all of us it's
sort of a wake-up call you think you're
running your life with your wishes and
desires it's an illusion you're really
running your life with your programs
acquired from other people in our mind
we start to realize that we're concerned
we're afraid we don't have enough I'm
not safe I'm not secure and I say oh
these thoughts I was talking about the
thoughts in your mind go in and control
your biology your genetics your
physiology and your health and I go yes
this is really true I said well how can
I tell you what your thoughts are in a
sense that can I read your thoughts and
I say yes you know I could put wires on
your head and it's called
electroencephalograph and I could read
your brain activity and I go oh great I
can see this brain activity
I want to tell you something that's
profoundly important
we were programmed to believe that our
thoughts are contained in our head that
if I have a thought it's just for me not
for anybody else it's inside and it's
working through me
and now I want to tell you about a new
technology it's not
electroencephalograph it's called
Magneto encephalograph I say what's
unique about that I say read your brain
I say yeah but so does EEG I say yeah
but EEG put the wires on the head and
you get the electrical activity
conducted through the skin from the
brain and that's what I'm reading and I
said what's different about Meg
the probe is out here
and I said what does that mean
your thoughts are not contained in your
head your thoughts are broadcast to the
field just like a radio broadcast I said
well what if I as an individual have a
thought that says let's have peace in
the world
and I broadcast out there on the street
and I say let's have peace and I look
around it's like where's the piece I
don't see the peace and here's what the
relevance is
each of us is broadcasting
if you get enough people
to have the same thought
that broadcast is Amplified
each of us has a small power
but if you put a thousand people the
same thought ten thousand a hundred
thousand people with the same thought
you are broadcasting a most powerful
thought not just in your body but out in
the field I say your Energy's in the
field the thought is in the field and
you go well what does that mean and then
I'll give you this most wonderful quote
I used it the other day in a lecture
from Albert Einstein
and the quote is so important here's the
quote
the field so a definite definition the
field is the invisible energy right now
you're in a field there's cell phone
broadcast television television radio
broadcast all kinds of information
coming across but guess what each one of
you is a broadcast in that field the
quote the field
is the sole governing agency of the
particle
particle is the material Realm
so what was Einstein saying it's the
energy in the field that shapes the
physical experience of our lives and if
enough of us collectively have an energy
that's coherent and strong and we
broadcast the belief we change the world
I just want you to recognize as much as
I wanted peace in the world if not
enough people are out there saying let's
have peace in the world there is no
peace
if I want to say let's have a war how
can you have a war you have to have
enough people convinced that the war is
going to benefit them so that their
broadcasts say yes let's have a war
because I and my colleagues we're all
going to have a better result from that
and the reality is this
the only things that change on this
planet collectively are when we
collectively share thoughts
and yoga when you're in your postures
when you're in your process your mind is
sharing a thought not just in your head
but all around you so the whole idea
about this is we have to recognize we
are collectively creating reality with
our thoughts and if we want to change
reality it can change instantly
the moment we become coherent the moment
we collectively are on the same platform
of thinking you get enough people to say
peace there will be peace instantly in
this world
but we've been programmed by other
people to give them the power to tell us
what we need
and as side Vegeta has been telling us
so importantly what we need is not what
they tell us what we need is what we
know
and I really hope that you understand
this because when you have your thoughts
recognized it's not contained in your
head your thoughts out in the field and
that thought the field is the soul
governing agency of matter
and therefore what this world is looking
for at this moment is an evolution
it's not an evolution of our biology our
biology has already evolved
it's an evolution of our consciousness
when we collectively as a population say
enough is enough it will end
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to
activate the Law of Attraction check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe I'll
see you there the moment you're
empowered and feel it you're beginning
to step towards your success the moment
you start feeling whole your Healing
Begins and when you love yourself and
you love all of life you'll create an
equal now you're causing an effect